well let's take you back to our top
story and that news coming out of Russia
that it's about to ban those countries
except price caps against its petroleum
products Thomas O'Donnell is an energy
analyst and lecturer at herty school of
governance joins me now via Skype from
Berlin Mr Thomas good to have you with
us on the program thanks for your time a
very short notice it seems we've got
like a Tit for Tat uh issue going on
here and this is a response really by
what the EU and other groups have
already done against Russia's petroleum
products
yes uh it certainly is
um I have to say to me this seems like a
bit of bravado on Mr Putin's part
um this is quite uh you know experts can
argue about how effective the price cap
will be and we can discuss that but the
fact is you have
outstanding Unity of the entire EU G7
and so forth very broadly on an
agreement to a very harshly sanction
Russian oil the EU is taking no more oil
by sea since the fifth of this month and
by the 5th of February they won't take
any more refined products by sea from
Russia that's a stunning hit to Russia
and now they will enforce this price cap
worldwide anybody who wants to use any
ships insured from the European Union
will have to re you know respect this
and already I know I was watching
looking at Bloomberg's latest data a day
or two ago and the shipments from Russia
and the European side the Baltic area
had dropped by 50 percent in the early
part of December when this cap was
imposed so is this in fact bravado from
Putin oh we're going to cut supplies
when they're already being forced to
have a significant hit to their supplies
where do you stand on the fact that the
price cap itself is slightly above what
a barrel of oil normally costs so it
does allow Russia to have that little
bit of profit even though its Market has
been
drastically reduced by those countries
that will ban it but it does give a
glimmer of hope to countries like India
that really need oil and have to import
it from all sources
well just to be clear whether you agree
with the tactic or not
the EU made a very as we as I discussed
a big cut
and by Administration is a little bit
worried this is so much of the world's
oil that they want they thought look
it's important that the oil keeps
flowing to countries like India and
China and turkey is another one that's
been taking quite a lot but let's try to
keep the price limited so that's where
this idea of the price cap instead of
right away putting some kind of
secondary sanctions on other people who
bought the oil that Europe now and the
United States refused to take fine as
Janet Yellen said when she visited uh
India or some weeks ago buy all you want
just do it below the price cap
now you can argue about where it's set
right now because the price of oil that
is being sold at Russian oil is actually
below that but it's a mechanism
and that mechanism will be reviewed
periodically by the European Union the
United States and the G7 and will be
couldn't be squeezed squeezed squeezed
and this is very daunting I think uh for
mascots over time indeed I mean they can
squeeze it as much as they want but at
the end of the day uh Europe uh the g70s
you say the United States and Australia
they still need oil they have to get
other sources you know we saw the us
trying to push OPEC to pump more uh
earlier this year but it didn't really
have any impact and it's irked the U.S a
great deal that relationship between oil
producing countries and them
okay personally I think the Biden
Administration made two too public of a
of a uh of a what we say stomach budding
between two sides and this with OPEC I
think they should have gone a little
lighter really there is a recession
coming uh I mean most you know Banks or
most financial institutions will say it
looks like there's going to be a
significant recession this year in
Europe and perhaps the United States not
as strongly and other places and
meanwhile China is having great
difficulties coming out of covet
eventually there will eventually be the
demand so you know just from a market
point of view OPEC might have a point
they're actually afraid that the market
would be oversupplied and I think it's a
complex situation the Biden
Administration is thinking more long
term we want to keep enough oil on the
market Not to cause a spike and slowly
squeeze the Russians there's no question
that in the long run the West when the
signals are there the I mean the Saudis
the UAE uh and the United States can
produce so much more oil in the long run
they can take this Market away from
Russia already the Saudis are moving to
take the Lost Market in Europe so
um it's yeah that's how I that's how I
look at it I just have to wait and see
what happens I want the uh the feedback
is it is it is a very interesting chess
game at the moment and for that moment
we have to leave it uh Thomas O'Donnell
are joining us from Berlin thanks very
much for your time sir
thank you sir good night